[Music]
can you trust Cortazar videos to answer
this question will first explain how we
research them and then talk a bit about
past videos and what we want to achieve
with the channel making a cortázar video
always begins with a question or an
issue for example after our meet video
many viewers asked about the health
effects of meat on humans we had no idea
that were pretty curious too so we just
decided to work on it the first step is
research we start by looking for books
and scientific papers to get an overview
and just read a lot the plan is to find
a story worth telling
is there something surprising to learn
is there a larger context or a new
perspective or will it be an overview or
introduction once we have the first
readable version we reach out to experts
or scientists and ask them to fact check
and correct us often enough they find a
flaw or point us in the direction of
contradictory research at this point
many scripts die if our idea does hold
up we continue working on it this
process can take weeks or months our
lonliness script for example took over a
year and a half to finish the hardest
part is being brief while not
simplifying too much it's much easier to
write a long script than a short one
when we're finally done we do another
round of research and show the strip to
experts again ideally different ones
than the ones we talked to at the
beginning of the process when we express
an opinion we mark it as such that's not
saying that we don't draw conclusions
from the research homeopathy does not
work and meat is really bad for the
planet climate change is real but
organic food is not a good way of
solving it if the facts clearly support
a conclusion it's OK to present it as
such of course we can't always make
everybody happy
people who know a lot about a topic
sometimes get annoyed if we don't
mention an aspect they think is crucial
or when we omit technical terms this is
more or less unsolvable because of the
nature of our videos scripts have around
1300 words so there's always some degree
of simplification you will always find a
list of our research and sources and
further reading material in the video
description just citing sources doesn't
make your work accurate or your research
good though so we encourage you to use
our sources document as a starting point
to look at the topic yourself and learn
more but it would be dishonest to say
that we've always worked this way some
order videos don't live up to the
standards we set ourselves today the two
that annoy us the most are the refugee
and addiction videos in both of them we
didn't try to present a balanced
perspective but instead chose a take and
ran with it the refugee video was made
with a deep feeling of an angry
frustration about the world at the high
point of the 2015 refugee crisis while
we argued over quotas dead children
washed ashore on our coastlines the
script was written on one Sunday
afternoon and illustrated and animated
within a week it was exhausting
stressful and frustrating we still
believed it was the right thing for
European countries to help but it was
absolutely unnecessary to be toxic about
it we insulted people and brushed away
their concerns about real and profound
challenges the video was divisive and
emotional at a time when the debate
needed a calm and clear overview the
addiction video was based on only one
source that has amassed a lot of
criticism over the years and
unfortunately we did not reach out to
scientists or do extra research on the
papers that were the basis for the
videos thesis that addiction is purely
psychological and based on the life
circumstances of the individual this
stance is still held by a number of
addiction professionals and we're not
saying it's wrong but a lot of others
disagree and it's not correct to present
it as the truth the diction is far from
solved and our videos should have
reflected that instead of taking one
site
we simplified an idea so much that it
made a great story but became distorting
both videos were made over the span of
two months and they're two of our most
successful videos to date we had found a
formula that really worked but we never
made anything like them again and have
been discussing how to deal with them
for a long time it doesn't help that
both videos are loved by many people we
want to be proud of our work and these
two videos don't make us proud so today
we deleted them it won't purge them from
the Internet but that's not the goal
anyway feel free to upload them
elsewhere we're working on a new
addiction video that we'll take a look
at the chemical and psychological causes
we'll take our sweet time with it so
please have patience the refugee video
is not up to date anymore so we will not
renew it we're also going through our
older videos to add sources further
reading and comments in the next few
months nowadays rather than trusting in
mainstream institutions we often look at
creators on the internet for reliable
information we rely on the fact that
they're careful and rigorous and not led
by monetary incentives and we expect
them to acknowledge mistakes in public
and work to minimize them so this is
what we're going to do Trust is not a
thing you are once and then keep forever
you have to constantly work for it so
can you trust courts cos art you can
trust that every video we make is
thoroughly researched and approved by
different experts you can trust that we
know that we have biases and we try to
overcome them we want to move cuts cos
out further towards the trustworthy end
of the spectrum the world is too complex
for simple answers and we don't want to
be the ones giving them making these
videos over the last six years has been
quite a ride and we're very grateful for
it we hope you'll be with us for the
next few years too and join us on our
journey to figure out what this universe
and life stuff is all about thank you
for watching
you